j'ai la flemme le tam-tam non je le fais
pas il ya des trucs dans la poubelle
elle est vide je me suis trompé
bon on a tous des phases de l'ag une
phase où je remets un ou dix ça me fait
plaisir c'est si on a tous des phases
dans notre vie vous le savez parfois on
adore quelque chose trois mois après on
n'est plus du tout et on a l'impression
que quelque chose a changé que c'est
pour ça qu'on n'est plus alors que nos
justes les goûts et les couleurs
évoluent c'est comme ça il faut assumer
des volumes en ce moment je suis dans
une phase mois où j'adore apprendre des
choses ça a commencé avec ces trucs
d'apprendre comment sont fabriqués les
choses qui m'entourent et quel régal en
vrai j'ai vraiment kiffé cette phase là
je commence à un peu moins qui fait
parce que bah tu deviens fou en fait des
fois j'ai écouté de musique sur une
enceinte et je faisais mais c'est quoi
le son comme en en fait du son sort de
voiliers ce truc ton cerveau bugs
vous voyez black magic factory c'est le
nom de ce président aujourd'hui c'est le
paradis ce ne sont que des vidéos de
trucs qui sont hyper beau à voir mais
qu'on ne va pas comprendre
évidemment et je suis nul en sciences
c'est confirmé c'est validé depuis une
certaine vidéo va pas revenir dessus
je vais être spectateur comme vous et et
c'est forcément je l'amenais des
touristes sur la table qui vont être
chasseuse jeudi d'avancement voulait pas
mais je pourrais pas m'empêcher
commencions avec cette vidéo qui a
énormément tourné ou en gros tout le
monde pense que c'est un gars qui a
voyagé dans le temps regardez c'est une
caméra de surveillance donc c'est
dégueulasse 1 j'ai hâte que toutes les
cartes urgences ou en 1080 il ya ce gars
qui marche derrière ce gars qui au
premier plan celui qui marche derrière
tape sur l'épaule du gard au premier
plan et ça lui permet de faire attention
et d'esquiver tout simplement une
barrière en métal qui l'aurait peut-être
tu es jolie et lui comprend pas je sais
pas si c'est fake je sais pas si c'est
monté toute pièce auquel cas ça reste
trop fort bien joué
[Musique]
au nôtre via autsai et j'ai envie de
faire ça aurait dit il ya des humains
mignon ce n'est pas le thème retenu nos
petits tours de magie sympa sympa ça
arrive pas à la cheville de détours
qu'on s'est fait que jordan mais c'est
bien c'est bien la dynamique des fluides
godmode ça ça me rend malade
ça me rende ma comment tu peux à ce
point maîtriser la trajectoire d'un
liquide sous on a tous tenté en faisant
un t on à tout ce temps et quand chez
elle au maroc pour les 10 juin la bonne
et j'ai tenté bon de manière beaucoup
moins d'un gain et j'ai quand même raté
c'est super dur apparemment les bulles
rebondit sur les lasers vous le saviez
évidemment non
salom mais ça alors mais à hassaï et le
moment où elle gère sans que cette vidéo
on est de retour en 2014
on va juste faire dans mes coups de feu
comment c'est possible au web ce truc
que ma petite soeur à fabriquer alors
personne ici n'a la même petite soeur
que lui je le sens attention bon déjà
trop stylé tout ça m'énerve ça me fera
sur l'acteur d'iron man
[Musique]
on n'a pas le même petite soeur ça c'est
évident écoutez moi bien ça ne vaut pas
du tout ma main en carton à aucun moment
je suis désolé ce que j'ai le sommes
parce que sa petite soeur m'éclate en
activité manuelle évidemment des flammes
hydrographique appliquer un casque trop
de mots complexes
j'ai juste compris le mot casque
ah oui j'ai vu cette technique
d'impression sais où je ne n'ai jamais
comprises mais je l' ai vu c'est même
pas la même couleur et tout va saisir
les gens les gens là qu'on fait est ce
qu'on y va la ram n'est pas une boîte
sombre
[Musique]
mon style est assez génial tellement
fort marketing sont tellement forts
c'est tellement une bonne idée ce qui
ouvre c'est que quand il ouvre la porte
le jouer bush un poil comme si on voyait
la fin de ce mouvement quand il fait
genre qu'ils n'étaient pas en train de
faire la fête
regardez c'est incroyable trop fins
meilleure idée vous ressenti ça aussi
des fois vous voyez un truc tellement
génial que ça vous énerve que des gens
soient si géniaux ah oui le frapper m un
gyroscope dans une boîte je connais noz
man il m'avait montré ces gyroscopes et
ouais j'ai déjà touché gyroscope de
neumann et toi alors ça fait quoi de le
mettre dans une boîte pas trop bien
[Musique]
alors neumann tu l'avais pamir dans une
boîte toi le bouclier d'invisibilité
attends attends attends
attend ce jour est arrivé la cape
d'harry potter est maintenant disponible
dans la vraie vie le jour est arrivé
c'est pas parfait mais c'est ouf je
suppose que c'est une manière de laver
ton les six pions
[Musique]
demain en avion d'un but à 4 cm on a vu
on a très bien vu ta bozoum maîtres au
ralenti où on comprend pas plus
malheureusement mais ça c'est les chefs
qui escaladent cédé il ya des chefs qui
est qui monte dans les arbres comme ça
dans certains pays c'est waou dauphin
c'est impressionnant mais je connaissais
on dirait que ce monde n'a plus de
secret pour moi il ya certains pays
comme ça ou où tu retrouves souvent des
chèvres à ses hôtes dans les arbres est
en fait l escalade super bien et on s'y
attend pas du tout on dirait pas envers
une chef qu'elle est capable d'escalader
permet alors je crois pas que ce soit
toutes les chèvres je vois qu'il ya
certaines chefs qui ont grandi dans
certains endroits qui sont capables de
faire ça ça y est je ne peux pas
m'empêcher donner une explication qui
est probablement très fausse je suis
désolé j'ai fait ça pour un projet
d'école les petits bouts qui volent
c'est du polystyrène par le petit bout
qui volent c'est du polystyrène et ça va
on est où là
tu peux pas faire une pancarte ont comme
projet d'école comme tout le monde c'est
un prix ça non je n'ai aucune idée de la
nation ce qui se cache derrière cet
objet mais je trouve ça cool ça faisait
par contre ça fait un bruit très chiant
à je sais ce que c'est je les ai vus et
toc
ce perso supportable ce sont des hélices
holographique et ça ils commencent à en
avoir même dans certaines boutiques et
ça te fait un hologramme comme dans les
films de science fiction quoi regarder
voilà
c'est dingue je m'étais vachement
intéressé à cette technologie parce que
je me suis dit ça va peut-être changer
la tête de nos villes en fait jean tête
que les pumas non ça va vraiment être ce
à quoi comme dans ghost in the shell
dans le cul le clip de l'hymne à 6 tout
ça et j'en ai vu une envie folle dans
une boutique gt gt sauce et je me dis
[ __ ] ça y est c'est fait le futur est
là une pièce de fuse je n'ai pas la trad
refuse de quitter sa veste
ouah
ouah c'est une plume est-ce que c'est
pas le même phénomène
attention la communiquer est-ce que
c'est pas le même phénomène que quand tu
quand tu fais ça là je le sais je le
seul gars sur youtube qui a des ballons
de baudruche est à portée de main c'est
très révélateur j'adore quand tu fais ça
là et que c'était cheveux après bon moi
je commence à pas trop hadj de cheveux
mais après tes cheveux de ses y suivre
le ballon est-ce que c'est pas le même
phénomène que ça je me demande un
costume incroyable de l'homme invisible
est ici servi du bouclier d'autres
non
ouah alors je pense que ça rend vraiment
bien en vidéo mais qu'en vrai il est
juste derrière ça se voit il est
derrière son truc en fait
dans la vidéo on ne voit pas trop mais
je pense quand tu le vois de profil il
est deux fois plus épais qu'un gars
normal et il est pas visible je suis un
rabat joie à chaque fois
[Musique]
mais il est beaucoup trop chaud mais là
il a même pas touché jordan on est à
chier
j'adore quand le tour il est méga saint
thual a juste le concept du le filtre
tourner tout le temps au bout et c'est
hyper simple et sobre cette foule
vraiment bien sommes bravo bravo tu nous
as bien foutu le som frais aux animaux
blé pain presque de la même couleur que
le ciel non mais faut arrêter que vos
délires d'invisibilité vous nous rendait
dingue j'ai besoin que le jet d'un x men
il va aller au point est réel un jour là
en vrai c'est fou qui n'est pas une
techno d'invisibilité genre un écran
ultra réaliste qui prend la même couleur
que ce cas autour de toi je parle d'un
truc qui flotte dans du mercure ah ouais
ça flotte
oui parce que les propriétés du mercure
font que du couple le métal à ce contact
est qu'est-ce que j'aimerais pouvoir
dire une phrase comme ça une vraie
qu'est ce que c'est que ça dentifrice
c'est l'un des tous les plus mystérieux
le dentifrice pour moi je vous jure
c'est tellement puissant avec du coca
pareil tellement puissant ainsi le coq a
tellement acide
[Musique]
non mais attends
non mais attends je suis désolé mais si
tu bois du coq avec une brosse les dents
directement après il se passe quoi en
fait là je deviens parano la haine
envers le secret du truc c'est ça
cécilia danse verte voilà ils nous
disent pas à ce que la danse vert j'ai
montré à mon manager la vidéo du rouleau
de ruban et du compresseur d'air alors
il m'a envoyé ça je sais pas la vidéo
dont il parle ouah
[Musique]
oh je viens de vivre un choc il y avait
un jeu harry potter vous l'avez ou pas
là il ya de certains trous qui est de
faire au oui je sais ce qui m'attire
vous l'avez ou pas le jeu et potter où
il y avait exactement ce phénomène mais
ça veut ça vient de le rappeler ça y est
le jeu c'était ça soufflait ya une balle
qui volait et il fallait faire tout un
parcours et réussira à ce que la balle
arrive au d'un point a à un point b sans
tomber moi je viens d'avoir un choix que
j'avais complètement oublié jeu et
j'espère ne pas apprendre tout à fait de
l'amiante dodo et enfin joe si c'était
vous êtes très nombreux à vous aviez eu
le jeu des empreintes digitales l'add on
apparaît dans cette vidéo
bonne chance les avions ne sont pas
censés faire ça
[Musique]
attends mais c'est un graviou c'est un
avion télécommandé je n'arrive même pas
à savoir
on est où là c'est un avion qui prend
pas en hélicoptère on est bien d'accord
avec ça alors je n'ai rien compris ça me
terrorise je sois pas expliquer pourquoi
ça me fait peur ça y est ce beach
j'adore une vidéo elle commencé quelques
des éléments qui ne vont pas ensemble
il ya une sorte de bouchon liège une
bougie en liquide et un bout des pins du
dans le liège vega vous n'êtes pas en
train de préparer les démonstrations de
deux phénomènes scientifiques à tout
hasard
bon allez montrer nous je sais pas où
ils veulent en arriver mais ça tourne
ok la bougie chauffe le métal devait y
avoir un truc entre le métal chaud le
liège et de liquide qui fait que c'est
tout
non mais alors ça alors là je suis
désolé j'aurais pu faire une activité
manuelle voyage pas vous dire mais il
est une structure géante en nouvelle
zélande qui donne l'impression d'être un
morceau de papier façon cartoon
[Musique]
je n'arrive pas y croire c'est tellement
bien réussi que je n'arrive pas à
concevoir que c'est réel j'ai réellement
l'impression que c'est photoshop je peux
pas imaginer autre chose je n'arrive pas
à imaginer autre chose
[Musique]
et qu'est-ce que ça fout là je suis
désolé il a pété la bouteille zoolander
d'accord waouh je suis déconcerté
je sais pas quoi dire qu'est-ce qui l'a
l'océan là qu'est ce que c'est ah mais
c'est un truc connu ça c'est là c'est la
séparation
ça c'est le même phénomène que l'huile
et le vinaigre j'aimerais répondre à
toutes vos questions j'ai adoré et
j'aimerais vous puissiez répondre ben
ouais c'est une sécurité ou en groupe
des capucins un certain niveau de
résistance dans ce que le truc est en
train de découper la lame se retire donc
imaginons que c'est un doigt à la place
du bois d'un coup et bien la lame se
retire ce qui fait que le l'employait
n'est pas blessé c'est incroyable le
doit représenter bien sûr par cette
agréable saucisses ce tour d'autres
défiant la gravité regarder jusqu'à la
fin
[Musique]
mais pourquoi l'école moi c'était pas ça
c'est dingue parce qu'à l'époque quand
j'avais l'âge des gens l'accueillent
dans cette classe g mais pas du tout la
physique-chimie genre pas du tout et
maintenant c'est un truc que je trouve
hyper intéressante mais du coup je crois
que même si à l'époque j'avais eu des
cours comme ça j'aurais été le gars qui
dort au fond de la classe quoi jean
jaurès a été intéressant et si j'y
retourne
actuellement je serai un mec de 24 ans
milieu d'enfants de 15 ans c'est très
clip x écoutez nous sommes à la fin de
ce bris dit j'espère qu'il vous a plu en
ce moment j'ai besoin d'être émerveillé
je crois il ya tellement une négative
cette année ça me fait trop du bien
juste de vous voir des trucs comme ça et
de faire ouah city de la vidéo c'est
aussi pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a fait ce
truc de magie avec jordan c'est que la
magie c'est exactement ce à quoi s'est
tu vois un truc tu fais oies et on
dévoile le secret tu fais à paoua en
fait je veux tu m'as bien douillet je
vous dis à bientôt je vais pas vous
passer de très bonnes vacances normand
c'est les vacances pour me faire d'entre
vous courage pour ceux qui sont encore
au taf a très vite
[Musique]
oh
non